enjoying the Summer Sunshine in downtown
Kiev at times it's possible to forget
this is a country at War but look closer
and you see the reminders of the
economic pain this conflict has brought
people selling what few possessions they
have on the streets
and the lines of people waiting for a
hot meal have lengthened
twice a week Vladimir velikodne and his
volunteers organize food distribution
for people who'd otherwise go hungry
When The War Began we found we were
feeding more internally displaced people
who've come from the occupied cities in
duned luhanskenzapur Asia they're in a
very bad State and they came here
without anything
in poor health petrochevkovy struggles
to live on a pension that doesn't keep
Pace with spiraling prices
a lot of my money goes to medicine and
the price of everything in the stores
keep going up and up my pension doesn't
go far enough according to the World
Bank the number of people in Ukraine
living in poverty Rose from just over
five percent at the start of the war to
a quarter of the population by the end
of last year while a growing number of
households are struggling to pay for
basic necessities like food and
utilities
as the war continues so the number of
people being displaced and falling into
poverty increases
Anastasia costinkova has just arrived in
Kiev with her twin daughters from the
Eastern Frontline town of Torres after
struggling to stay there since the start
of the war
leaving behind their home and most of
their possessions she and her family are
starting over
the shop I worked closed that's how it
is before the war we had stability and
normal life I had a job and my husband
had a job
this is a war that's being measured not
only in lives lost on the front lines
but also in the livelihoods left in
Ruins far from the fighting Rob McBride
Al Jazeera Keith